We are here in Soho Square, London
and we're going to see if people
can receive our serve
for £100!
Oh my days!
You have probably come
to the wrong park
because we've got a lot of
good players here!
We've heard big talk
from this park!
I can’t believe that!
That was crazy!
I didn’t even get a chance!
You’re leaving a lot of space over there?
Oooooh!
Going for a big forehand!
He knows how to play!
Oooh!
I don't play
I just want to try
It might be an advantage
It might not but...
it’s okay!
But I hit it!
That’s good!
Let’s see if the force
is with me on this one!
Let’s go!
Okay you’re standing over there
Have you played before?
Yeah I’ve played!
Okay!
Got it wrong!
What!?
Pongfinity, right?
Yeah!
I see your videos!
What's your strongest side?
Backhand
I think so!
One more!
Last try
I tried!
Nice to meet you!
All right
Watch and learn!
That’s famous last words!
Believe in yourself
I believe!
Come on, you can do it!
Good luck!
Okay, thank you so much!
Yea, I’m a good player!
I need luck and support
from the audience!
Come on!
Ooooohhh!!
He’s got it!
I got it!
Thank you so much
That was easy!
Hundred quid
Just like that!
Amazing!
Thank you so much!
If you receive our serve
you get £100
Deal?
We've got our next challenger here!
Look at his grip
Just have the money ready!
That was close!
Good serve
Thank you
Good one!
He's been saying
he’s the best one in the park, right?
One of the best!
This is my lucky bat
Okay
You took it before it even bounced!
So nervous!
I was so nervous!
I need to prepare myself, you know!
You gotta see
where the ball is coming
Keep the eye on the ball
Keep the eye on the ball!
You ready?
I think so!
I wasn’t even ready for that!
Keep the eye on the ball!
What's your name?
Aitor
Okay Aitor, nice to meet you!
Can I try one more?
Changing the grip?
I don't know!
I never played before!
I will try to...
make a point!
So much spin!
You're not going to give me a hint?
I'm not going to give you a hint!
At least you touched it!
I'll go change my t-shirt
and come back!
Yeah!
All right Joanna, good luck!
I'm going to try a new serve
That's the world's fastest serve
for you guys!
Keep the channel going!
Yeah, we will!
Thank you!
Thanks for coming
Otto, they're not all here for us!
No?
So what's your name?
Joseph
Nice to meet you!
I’ve watched you guys for three years
Oh, really?
Yea!
Like you and Emil
And Otto
of course Otto!
Let's hope you can get it!
Surprise me!
Ooohh
Relax
Okay that’s my bad
Last one was close!
Good luck
Cheers, mate!
I had to go for a short one
because you were standing
all the way back there!
How confident are you feeling?
I’m not confident!
Well that is hard!
It’s the spin!
You got a good position!
How did it feel?
It’s difficult to receive
Subscríbidos al canal de
Pongfinity
Muy bien!
Have you played before?
No, I haven’t
Ooooh!
That was this close!
That was one of the closest ones so far
Oh?
Good try!
Thank you!
Very impressive!
What’s the name of your channel?
Pongfinity
Awesome
Receive one of our serves
Ok
Okay!
He has a good racket
I got a feeling he’s gonna
rip it!
Oooohh!
Thank you
If it didn't come to the body
it’d be okay
Just gotta return the ball?
Yeah!
You think you're going to do it?
I feel all right!
Maybe
Ohohohhoh!
And he whipped it!
Just smashed it in!
That was amazing!
Congratulations!
Thank you!
Am I on YouTube now?
Called
Pongfinity
You can
make sure you go and subscribe!
Thank you guys!
All right, me and the misses
are going to get pissed!
Kinda moving nuts that ball!
Can’t control it!
Quite nearly!
Easy, respect for that!
You got it!
Last one
Oh!
This is serious!
If it spins like this
you have to pull it up!
Okay, nah!
I’ve got a feeling you have played before!
I play, yeah!
Oooooh
That was nasty!
Need to push more!
Thank you!
Not bad!
That was this close!
So close!
Wait!
Give me a moment!
Ok yeah!
Take your time!
Are you from Norway?
Finland
Finland!
Okay!
Denmark!
Ah nice!
Finland will win!
That was close!
I think Miikka is going to serve...
Hold the racket like that
Okay, cool
Sorry!
I had to do it!
I had to!
What’s your name?
Julia
What’s your guys’ YouTube channel?
It’s called Pongfinity
Subscribe on YouTube
Thank you!
Have you played before?
Never!
It just kicked!
Thank you
That was good
Let's hear some cheer for Dimitri!
I will do it now!
I don't even know which hand
No strategy!
I'm just going to whack it!
Unlucky!
Wow!
She got it!
Yes!!
I had a strategy obviously!
Hit it up!
Well done!
Thank you so much!
Nice, thank you!
It's going very well!
What's the strategy?
Counteract the spin!
Counteract the spin?
As long as you know the theory...
I'm feeling it!
Ooh long day...
I give it to boss man
he’ll counteract the spin
So the...
the master of counteraction
How do you counteract the spin?
Who knows?
That was close!
I'm from Italy
Are you nervous?
No!
Let's see your hands!
No, no, no!
Okay, you ready?
Yeah!
Good try!
Oooohh!
You got it!!
Yo sup!
That was so good!
Here you go!
Thank you so much!
Hundred quid
Have a nice weekend!
The next person
to receive the serve
will be the last challenger!
It’s like everybody!
The one who catches the ball
gets to go next!
Okay you got it!
Send it!
That wasn’t really close!
Oh my days!
There's so many people
we can't take everybody!
I’ll tell you 18 numbers
of pi right now!
If you get them all
you’ll get to go next!
I thought you said 80
18!
I’m just serving where he is not standing!
Nice try!
You’ve got a Supreme sticker?
He's got a card!
Alexis Sanchez holo
I guess that's impressive?
You’re giving me your...?
What is this?
Credit card?
Shrek’s adventure?
Shrek vs. Alexis Sanchez
We'll have you both
You go first!
Do it for Alexis Sanchez!
Yeah, exactly bro!
All right, last one!
Too bad!
So next up, Shrek!
Yea!
Inshallah!
Oooooohh!
He’s got it!!
The last one to get it on!
Team Shrek!
Ay!
I want to thank my mom!
She was here since day one!
I made it out!
Subscribe to Pongfinity!
You heard it!
Let us know in the comments
where you want us to do this challenge next!
And we'll be there!